good morning the things that I want to
talk about today is a brand new course
that simply learned is offering that can
help you become a digital marketing
certified associate and I'm going to
give you a sort of a preview of some of
the content that we'll be sharing in the
course but first of all I guess I should
introduce myself i'm greg jarboe
and i'm also an instructor at the
rutgers business school in their many
MBA programs in both digital marketing
and social media marketing and I'm also
a faculty member in the interactive
advertising bureau's digital leadership
program now I also have my own firm I'm
the president and co-founder of a
company called SEO PR we are an
award-winning content marketing firm and
we've worked for a variety of different
clients and I some of that experience
with me into teaching the dmca course
many times I will share an anecdote or
an example of work that we've done to
illustrate a particular point I'm also
the author of a book called YouTube and
video marketing an hour a day that's
some of the content that I'm going to
share with you today to give you an idea
of the kinds of things that you'll learn
about YouTube in this particular course
I write for several and I write about
two blog posts that week and I've been
doing that now for well over 12 years so
that gives me about 1200 different blog
posts if you are interested in in doing
a google search you'll find that I've
written about a wide variety of topics
over the last several years and I'm a
frequent speaker at industry conferences
and mostly in North America and the
United States and Canada but also the
United Kingdom and I've spoken at other
conferences around the world and I'm
featured in a book that Michael Miller
wrote called online marketing heroes he
interviewed 25 successful online
marketing gurus
I was one of them and so that's what I
bring to the table hopefully some
experience a wide number of case studies
that either
I and my firm have been working on or
other people in the industry have
provided and I've interviewed them and
written their stories for a variety of
places but that brings me to why you're
here we're gonna be offering an new
course on digital marketing and part of
the reason we're doing this is because
the digital economy is growing
incredibly rapidly last year in 2014
about 40% of the world's population has
now has access to the Internet and
that's up from just 16% ten years ago so
the the penetration of particularly
using Wi-Fi devices in India has
increased the number of people who have
access to the Internet people are now
spending more than six hours a day
online either at work or pursuing their
own interests and we now spend more time
online with online media than we do
offline either watching a television
listening to the radio reading
newspapers or magazines so the world is
shifting and business recognizes us and
they're shifting more and more of their
operations online as well each ecommerce
is growing the two largest markets
happen to be China and the United States
but it turns out India is the third
largest market it is growing more
rapidly the the largest amount of growth
last year in new Internet users came
from India and so it's rapidly moving
into that top tier which makes India a
particularly interesting market for a
lot of different people including
for example Facebook and YouTube I wrote
an article in the real SEO blog just a
week or two ago talking about how India
has now become YouTube's second largest
market and that's because the u.s. is
still its largest market YouTube is
blocked in China as is Facebook and so
it turns out with the rapid growth of
access to the Internet in India India is
now YouTube's second largest market and
that makes it a perfectly interesting
one business is spending more money
online business is planning to spend
more money online so what does that mean
to you well this means that digital
marketing is not just a growing field
more and more companies have got digital
marketing budgets those budgets are
increasing at a fairly steep rate this
year according to the Gartner group
digital marketing budgets are likely to
increase 17% and the consequence of that
is that more and more companies are
adding more and more jobs in the digital
marketing space so in the United States
there is a job site called indeed and if
you look at it you'll see over 220,000
digital marketing jobs basically saying
we're we're trying to hire people with
this kind of background in India there
is also a job website called no Cree and
you'll find over 66,000 digital
marketing jobs on that website so again
the jobs are there and what's
interesting is that indeed did a salary
Data Report and discovered that the jobs
in digital marketing pay on average
eighty two percent more than traditional
marketing jobs so this is not only a
rapidly growing area it it pays well
so we've struck
should this course to help you prepare
for that kind of job will will give you
an overview of where digital marketing
fits in the overall marketing mix we
provide about 27 hours worth of detailed
instruction on topics like search engine
optimization social media marketing
pay-per-click advertising web analytics
content marketing email marketing wait
we cover a wide variety of disciplines
within digital marketing and then we
will focus on four projects these
projects are centered around key tools
that we think every digital marketer
will want to understand one of them is
Google Analytics which is the way most
people basically understand how the
traffic to their website what it did you
know how much they got what people went
on to let's say purchase a product or
filled out a lead generation form
another tool that we're going to focus
on is Google Adwords this is the world's
most popular pay-per-click advertising
platform and we will talk about it and
basically teach you how to use it
effectively we will also set up a
Facebook page as one of the projects in
in this course for a business we'll do
the similar thing for a YouTube channel
for a business and those are the four
projects that we will take you through
and some of your own time is going to be
involved in setting things up and
getting things ready to go to market
with a venture that you basically get to
create yourself you you you tell us what
business it is that you're going to
create and you will create a wordpress
blog in a Facebook page and a YouTube
channel and and and show us that your
you're ready you've got some hints on
experience basically adding web
analytics to that site getting ready to
launch an ad campaign that's almost most
of the course but we come back and we'll
finish the last session that we we go
through we'll talk about digital
marketing strategy and also managing a
digital marketing campaign everything
from from measurement to management so
all of that is included in the course
but I want to give you a sample that's I
think why why we're here give you sort
of a you know taste of the kind of
information that you learn and the
information I'm sharing today is some of
the content that we're going to be
covering on YouTube and the interesting
thing about YouTube is is that many
marketers have been there themselves to
watch videos but they're not entirely
clear on what the best practices are for
using YouTube for their own marketing
purposes so I'm going to quickly show
you four free tools that you can use to
make videos I'll talk to you quickly
about the step-by-step process for
setting up a YouTube channel for
business which is by the way free it
doesn't cost anything to do that it does
take a little in your time but it
doesn't you don't have to pay a fee to
set up a YouTube channel we'll talk
about what it will take to launch let's
say an advertising campaign on YouTube
using their true view ad platform and
then I'll talk about some different ways
that you measure results in in this new
medium so it turns out if you download
the YouTube app which is free it not
only lets you watch videos or share
videos with people you know
but it also has a feature that lets you
record video you can edit it with the
app you can add filters and music all
inside the app and then you can upload
that video to YouTube so again getting
started is incredibly simple it's also
free if you've never edited a video
before that sometimes sounds daunting
it's not it's a question of saying okay
I've just shot something here where do I
want to start where do I want to end
when I use the sound that I recorded
when I shot this do I want to add a
soundtrack all of which can be done from
the app if you're interested in a more
powerful product there's another one out
there called the YouTube video editor it
is also free and you basically can use
it to create new videos if you want or
it can take existing videos you already
have a lot trim them or clip them if you
decide you want to cut off that boring
beginning or that anticlimactic ending
you can edit your videos you can also
add music from a library of approved
soundtracks there's a number of special
effects that you can do use and and
again you can publish it to YouTube with
one click and that's that free option
now if you're more ambitious if one of
the things that you would like to do is
create something that tells a story then
there is another free app it's called
director and what I like about director
is it comes with storyboards basically
outlines that tell you if if for example
you're trying to create a how-to
tutorial here's some ideas for the
that you might want to shoot here's when
you might want to interview the expert
here's when you might want to show the
product here's how you might want to
edit that finally if you're going to add
a narrators voice do that here if you're
going to move things around as you're
editing that here's how you do that
and finally you you can save all your
fitted footage this tool is incredibly
powerful you can tell a wide variety of
stories there are hundreds of
storyboards there to guide you through
creating a wide range of different
genres and again the app is free and it
was such a popular one YouTube decided
to acquire the company and that's one of
the reasons why they can afford to give
this away for free that's their business
model and then YouTube took a version of
director and it also makes it available
for free as what is called the video ad
builder so if you've ever created a
40-second ad for your on for your
business video ad builder we'll give you
some very simple storyboards so you can
introduce your business in the first 10
seconds this is a just an example of
that kind of storyboard you know
basically state your name talk about
your business and then in the next 20
seconds share your enthusiasm for your
business what is it you do that you love
the most what do people who do business
with you seem to appreciate the most
what makes your business different than
some others and then close with a call
to action let people know that if
they're interested and getting more
information about you where they can
find that online or where your shop is
located so again building a video ad is
pretty straight
forward if you download the free app
follow the instructions use the
storyboard to even structure your first
first ad so again a lot of tools are
available that they don't cost anything
and if you want to create a channel a
YouTube channel for your business
we've held a variety of companies do
that one of the companies that we helped
recently was Thomson Reuters so we've
worked for large companies as well as
smaller ones and creating a channel is
free and getting started is you know can
take about 15 minutes where some
additional time might go however is if
you want to then take and customize your
channel so it doesn't look like every
other channel out there and it turns out
YouTube allows you to do a lot of
customization again at no cost in the
sense that YouTube is not charging any
money for this although it can take some
time and talent to pull all this
together and again we'll walk you
through this but basically you can
create channel art as that you can
upload it will look good on both desktop
devices as well as mobile devices and it
can then give your channel a look and
feel and that's part of what will set
you apart you can design a channel icon
and this is could be as simple as your
logo or it can be a small image that you
create that lets people know you know
when they see your content around
YouTube that is from you one of the
things that makes the YouTube channel
very powerful is it gives you the option
of if someone is coming to your channel
for the first time you can show them
what is called a channel trailer this is
like a movie trailer this is your your
preview your highlight your introduction
the first video you want people to see
if they then go on and subscribe to your
channel then obviously when they come
back they're no longer first-time
viewers so you get to show them
something different that's I what to
watch next module two people who have
been to your channel before and what you
can basically inform them of is I've got
a new video you might want to check that
out or I've got one of my most popular
videos I'd like you to see that now you
can basically suggest a visitors to your
channel what to watch next there are
some other tools that will allow you to
create sections and playlists all these
tools are for free very very powerful
channel management features and it
doesn't cost you anything you just need
to learn how to use them and then if you
decide you know I'm ready to start
thinking about advertising on YouTube up
until about September of this year I
would have to take you down a special
kind of area that would teach you how to
create YouTube ads it was a separate art
to itself which is explains why not as
people not as many people understand how
to do this well it turns out as of
September of this year
YouTube and it's video platform have
been totally integrated within the
Google AdWords platform which is the
most popular one in the world and now if
you want to create a video campaign it's
as easy and you're using the same
platform the same tools as you might if
you were gonna create a search ad or a
display ad now all you do is basically
say okay I want to create a video
campaign and it's now just a type of ad
format totally integrated within the
AdWords tool now even though it has been
integrated it turns out YouTube's
view ads have some unique features that
give video some additional power that
you won't find and let's say a display
ad or a text ad in search one of the
things that TrueView does is it gives
you this option called the in-stream
video ads and what will happen with an
in-stream ad is somebody will want to
come see a video it could be I want to
watch YouTube rewind which is the
highlights of the year but before
YouTube rewind starts an ad will appear
and the first five seconds of the ad
will begin playing and then a little
button will come up to say what you'd
like to skip ad that gives the user the
ability to say I don't want to watch an
ANA I want to go straight and watch
YouTube rewind and that's fine if
somebody hits the skip ad button the
advertiser pays nothing but if the
person does not hit the skip ad button
and they watch your ad for longer than
30 seconds or if your ad happens to be
particularly short let's say your ad is
only a 15-second ad then for the
duration of the ad or until they begin
interacting with you and your ad let's
say they they click on something in you
or add a link that will take them to
your webpage if somebody interacts with
your ad then and only then are you
charged that's why it's called true view
basically you're only advertising to
people who have chosen to watch your
advertising it is not intrusive it is
incredibly popular it's incredibly
powerful but it has this feature that
basically allows the users to skip the
ad if they're not interested and there's
also a version of this it's sister or
its brother if you will called the in
display video ad this doesn't appear
before a video runs it appears to the
side of the video generally over
area where related videos normally
appear and what there's very typical in
YouTube in a session is I'm gonna watch
one video when that video is over I'll
look off to the right to see what other
related videos I might want to watch
next
and there's your ad and again you don't
pay anything for it unless somebody
clicks to watch the ad now that then
begs the question okay if somebody
watches so what what does that do for
your business and it turns out YouTube
has wrestled with that issue as well and
come back with an incredibly innovative
solution one of the solutions I'm going
to share with you is called brand lift
and what YouTube will do for an
advertiser for free this doesn't cost
any additional money it's if you are
running an ad campaign in YouTube and
you decide I really like to know whether
I'm having any impact on increasing
brand awareness YouTube will take a
sample of the target audience that you
selected so I want to get let's say
outdoor enthusiasts those are the people
I want to show my video to about the
business that I have that provides white
water rafting trips a near one of the
national parks in the United States so I
only want to reach people who are into
whitewater rafting that's a it's not
everybody in the country it's people who
enjoyed that kind of out outdoor sport
well okay then you basically target that
group of people and what true view
enables you to do is to take a sample a
small subset of that target audience
each you want to run your ad against and
it won't show your ad to that group in
other words they are the holdback group
they don't see your and most of the rest
of the
audience that you've targeted and does
see you're at but 48 hours two days
after your campaign launches YouTube
sends out basically a survey to both
groups people who saw your ad people who
didn't see your head they asked a couple
of quick questions and about brand
awareness about brand preference about
ad recall and then basically give you
the comparison people who didn't see
your ad you know have this kind of brand
awareness of you people who have just
seen your ad have a different degree and
what what basically a number of surveys
that have been done using this free tool
have come back as the average company
sees about a 17-point lift in brand
awareness because they've run their ads
on YouTube so again you now get a
measurement a metric that you can use to
say did we improve brand awareness yeah
and I can measure it and it's
scientifically valid it's I'm not
guessing I'm not making estimates I'm
not calculating the number of
impressions I might have had and making
some assumptions I've got now to
demonstrate brand lift you also can
create hard data using website traffic
in the early days of YouTube people
would watch the video and then maybe a
day later or a week later might actually
go over and visit the client's website
but you couldn't connect those dots it
was hard to show that people watching a
video had then come to visit your
website now it's much simpler now what
YouTube is offering is a technology it
calls cards CA RDS cards sort of like a
deck of cards and what that is is
basically a link that can appear on the
video that people can click on and go to
a variety of places
including your website so you can now
drive traffic from a video straight to a
landing page on your website where you
may have products for sale or whatever
it is that you're trying to do so
driving traffic is now not only
measurable it always was measurable but
it is now simple for the user to take
advantage of it's not obscurely hidden
away somewhere down in the description
so that is a game-changer and then when
you get to your website one of the
things that Google has done is making a
lot easier to track what are called
conversions
not just I got a visitor to my website
they came they looked they wandered
around that went away I have no idea
what they did now you can actually begin
to say okay how many people who came to
my website from any number of places
including YouTube went on to you know
download a whitepaper subscribe to a
newsletter fill in a lead generation
form do some on-site
ecommerce download an app make a phone
call any number of different kinds of
quote conversions and that again is a
game-changer because now you're not just
measuring traffic
you're beginning to measure frankly
business and that makes it incredibly
more valuable and that also enables you
to then begin calculating the return on
marketing investment this is one of
those things that people have been
wrestling around with for about twenty
years how do you calculate this well it
turns out there's a formula for
calculating it we will go through that
in this course and by the way if you can
now measure not just the traffic that
you're generating but the conversions
that you're generating you can begin
calculating the revenue that a
particular campaign is producing and you
can then look at the cost of creating
that campaign and
doing basically the calculation to say
okay this was a profitable campaign it
didn't just build brand awareness it
generated traffic it generated leads it
generated sales had generated revenue
and it did all of that cost-effectively
we made money on this campaign now
before we end I want to give you one bit
of advice we're going to try to train
you and get you prepared to not only
take a certification exam but also to
turn in four different projects that
demonstrate that you've learned all of
this but you're at the beginning of a
very long journey I think it's a really
rewarding one I think it could be an
entire career but one of false
assumptions I just wanted to deal with
upfront is quote you can't learn will in
48 hours and never have to learn
anything ever again this is a rapidly
rapidly changing field to give you an
illustration of that I just wanted to
show you this data point when I started
writing the first book on YouTube back
in 2008 there were about 15 hours of new
video content uploaded every minute to
YouTube which meant I couldn't watch at
all there was no way you know but nobody
could watch at all and so people had a
variety of ways of finding the kind of
content that interested them
well that was 2008 this year in 2015
seven years later 400 hours of new video
content is being uploaded to YouTube
every minute and this means that as you
are learning how to be more adept at
YouTube marketing or any part of the
digital marketing mix
so are a lot of other people you have a
lot of competition it raises the stakes
in the game it means you have never
learned enough you always need to learn
more things change and you know you need
to change long with them so you will
begin this journey we will help you get
started in this field we will give you
the foundation as long as you understand
that it's not over at that point you're
in a very fast changing fast growing
business that will require you to stay
up to date and basically it's a fun
industry to be in but it's not a
slow-moving one and I want to conclude
this with a story of a small company
that took YouTube marketing and helped
turn its little business into a
multi-million dollar business in a short
period of time the name of this company
is Orabrush so our ABR ush and they were
founded by gentleman named dr. Bob
Wagstaff who had invented a tongue
cleaner that's right
who knew that you could clean your
tongue I mean there are toothbrushes
people understand that there is
mouthwash people understand that this
was something different this is a tongue
cleaner and the reason he created this
is it turns out most of the germs come
from your tongue and those are the terms
that give people bad breath so if you
want to cure bad breath you need to
clean your tongue and that's that's not
something everyone does yet they haven't
gotten into that habit it's a whole
different kind of idea and he found that
nobody wanted his product he would try
to get retail stores to put it on their
shelf they didn't want to put it on
their shelf he tried to sell the patent
to this invention
to some of the big companies out there
they didn't want to buy his patent at
one point he even bought television time
created an infomercial and tried to sell
his product direct on TV and he ended up
spending about $40,000 buying the
television time and he only sold a small
number of his products and each product
only cost about $7 so he lost a lot of
money it wasn't working so he went to a
marketing course at the University near
him in Utah Brigham Young University and
he basically said is there anyone here
who can help me and there was a student
in the back of the room Jeffrey Harmon
who basically said well have you heard
of YouTube and he said no I haven't and
Jeffrey said well I could help you and
he's and so dr. Bob basically said look
Jeffrey I've noticed that you've come to
school today on a bicycle but you're in
your 20s I'm 76 years old I have a
vintage motorcycle which I can't ride
anymore
I'll make you a deal I will trade you my
motorcycle if you'll put together a
marketing plan on how I can use this
youtube to sell Orabrush and Jeffrey did
the deal Jeffrey said fine and he got a
friend of his to sort of act in the
video he got another friend of his to
write a script for the video it cost
$500 to create the video $300
went to the scriptwriter the other $200
was for like equipment and things like
that but it costs them $500 but they
created this video a very funny video
called the bad breath test how to tell
when your breath stinks and if you look
down underneath you'll see that it has
almost 24 million views
and what is more significant is that
helped Orabrush sell 1 million of its
Orabrush tongue cleaners at $7 each so
again a $500 bit of marketing helped the
company make 7 million dollars in
revenue and it put the company on the
map using video and they didn't stop
there this would be a great story all by
itself but they didn't stop there they
also decided that it would be a lot more
effective if they could get retail shelf
space and the biggest retailer in the
United States is a company called
Walmart they've got 3,500 stores right
across the country and so Orabrush did
something also pretty amazing
they created a video for one person it's
called an unlisted video you can't watch
this video unless you are sent the URL
to the video if you get the URL to the
video and it's right there at the bottom
of the slide then you can watch it and
only then can you watch it you won't
find this in search you won't find it if
you go to their channel it's unlisted
but in this unlisted video Orabrush
basically told the buyer at Walmart
here's why you should stock our product
on your shelves in all 3,500 of your
stores and what Orabrush was hoping for
is that the buyer would say ok let's
let's have a meeting why don't you come
into Arkansas here where we're
headquartered and we'll talk about this
and we'll have a meeting well it turned
out there was no meeting or Orabrush
didn't get that call what they got
instead was an order for several hundred
thousand seven hundred and thirty five
thousand or a brushes
oh by the way can you distribute them to
our 3,500 stores and oh by the way can
you do that in about a month and so all
of a sudden a video creative for one
person but the right person engage that
person generated the order and so even
without getting millions and millions of
views you can see this this video now
has 56,000 views
why because it's been used as case study
and a lot of courses that I've been
teaching so I've been sharing this with
a lot of people I I shared the unlisted
not basically URL there with you but
what this basically you know a video for
one person basically got Orabrush into
Walmart in then that's something really
funny started happening some of our
brushes customers said this is great
it's you know curing my bad breath but
is it safe for me to use with my dog my
dog has bad breath and the answer is no
that's not an appropriate use of this
product but that was also a signal that
maybe there was a market for a new
product that would basically help cure
dog bad breath
so dr. Bob went back to work he invented
a new product and basically it was a
great concept but nobody knew if there
was actually enough market demand for it
so how do you find out are there enough
dog owners that would actually use this
if we brought this product to market
well Orabrush tested it and they tested
it in a number of different ways one of
which is they went to IndieGoGo a
crowdsourcing site and said look if we
can raise $40,000 in initial orders then
we'll go develop this product so raise
your hand donate some money if we get
enough money we'll go build this thing
well it didn't just raise $40,000 they
raised $60,000 so they brought the
product
and then they tested it and they tested
it and they changed the way that they
targeted this product because where do
you find people who might purchase it I
mean what what is the profile of that
audience so they had to do some
experimentation they experimented with
different content what happens if we get
a third-party testimonial does that help
us
you know improve and by the time they
were through with their testing they'd
finally found a way not just to get
people to watch the video but to get
people who watched the video to place
enough orders so that they can make a
big profit and so they launched the
product and within months they basically
were able to generate about a video with
about 4.3 million views
that generated over 75 thousand orders
from people for this new product that
would cure bad breath and dogs and they
made over two million dollars selling
that product literally in less than a
year after testing it and bringing it to
market so again ends the things that you
will learn here are lessons that you can
apply a little water brush has done it
they're now a multi-million dollar
company they have a big product line and
those are the kinds of stories that
we'll share with you but we're going to
cover a lot of other things as well
we're again we're going to cover search
engine optimization social media
marketing pay-per-click advertising web
analytics content marketing email
marketing this is this is just today is
just a sample of the kind of content
that you'll learn we will dig into a
different tool so in addition to YouTube
we're also going to look at Facebook and
Google Analytics and Google Adwords
and you're going to work on some
projects in addition to the material
that you'll learn in the core
and we hope to get you all ready for a
number of different certification exams
one of which is the online marketing sir
for a certified associate the OMC a test
normally had cost money to just take the
test that is bundled into your course so
if you take the dmca course through
simply learn that fee for that
certification test is is paid by simply
learn we also get you prepared for other
certification exams at Google or
Facebook or YouTube offer and you know
that's our goal that's what we're trying
to do we're trying to get you job ready
it takes about oh six weeks to take the
course there's element of the projects
that you can turn in that can take up to
three months that's at your pace we
understand that some of you you know are
have a day job already you're trying to
do this at night or on weekends to get
ready for your next career and so we we
try to provide you with that kind of
flexibility and we really want to give
you the skill sets so you can get into
the ground level although this is a
rapidly growing and changing field as I
mentioned and and so you're you're sort
of catching the tiger by the tail but we
think it's going to be an incredible
journey we think it'll be a great career
and that's what we're trying to prepare
to you for and if you decide that this
is the kind of course that will help you
on your way please sign up thank you
very much for your time I think we'll
call that call that a day
[Music]
Hey want to become an expert in digital
marketing then subscribe to the simple
learned Channel and click here to watch
more such videos turn up and get
certified in digital marketing click
here